in this video i want to familiarize
ourselves with negative numbers and also
learn a bit of how do we add and
subtract them and when you first
encounter them they look like this deep
and mysterious thing when we first count
things we're counting positive numbers
what does a negative number even mean
but when we think about it you probably
have encountered negative numbers in
your everyday life and let me just give
you a few examples so before actually i
give the example the general idea is a
negative number is any number less than
zero
less
than
less than zero and if that sounds
strange and abstract to you let's just
think about in a couple of different
contexts if i have if i have a
if we're measuring the temperature and
it could be in celsius or fahrenheit
let's just we're measuring it in celsius
and so let me draw a little scale that
we can measure the temperature on and so
let's say that this is zero degrees
celsius that is one degree celsius two
degrees celsius three degrees celsius
now let's say that it's a it's a pretty
chilly day and it's currently
it's currently three degree celsius and
someone who predicts the future tells
you that it is going to get four degrees
colder the next day so how cold will it
be how can you represent that coldness
well if it only got one degree colder we
would be at two degrees but we know we
have to go four degrees colder if we got
two degrees colder
if we got two degrees colder we would be
at one degree if we got three degrees
colder we would be at zero but three
isn't enough we have to get four degrees
colder so we actually have to go one
more below zero we have to go one more
below zero and that one below zero
we call that negative one
we call that negative one and so you can
kind of see that the number line as you
go to the right of zero on the number
line it increases in positive values as
you go to the left of the number line
you're going to have negative one then
you're going to have negative two you're
going to have negative three and you're
going to have depending on how you think
about it
you're going to have larger negative
numbers but i want to make it very clear
negative 3 is less than negative 1.
negative 3 there is less heat in the air
than negative 1. it is colder there's
there's less temperature there so a
large so let me just make it very clear
negative 100 is much smaller
much smaller
smaller
much smaller than
one or sorry much smarter than negative
one you might look at a hundred and you
might look at one and your gut reaction
to say wow a hundred is a much larger
number than one but when you think about
it negative 100 means there's a lack of
something negative hundred if it's
negative 100 degrees there's a lack of
heat so there's much less heat here than
if we had negative one let me give you
another example let's say in my bank
account today i have ten dollars
let me do this in a new color so let's
say today
today i have i have ten dollars ten
dollars now let's say i go out there
because i feel good about my ten dollars
and let's say i go and spend
let's say i go out there and i spend
thirty dollars
and for the sake of argument let's say i
have a very flexible bank one that lets
me spend more money than i have and
these actually exist so i spend thirty
dollars so what's my bank account going
to look like so let me draw a number
line here
and you might already have an intuitive
response i will owe the bank i will owe
the bank some money so let's let me
write this over here so tomorrow
tomorrow what is my bank account
so you might immediately say look if i
have ten dollars and i spend thirty
dollars
there's twenty dollars that have to come
from some place and that twenty dollars
is coming from the bank so i'm going to
owe the bank twenty dollars and so in my
bank account to show how much i have i
could say 10 minus 30 is actually
negative 20 dollars so in my bank
account tomorrow i am going to have
negative
negative 20
so if i say i have negative twenty
dollars that means that i owe the bank i
don't even have it not only do i have
nothing i owe something it's going in
reverse here i have something to spend
no one knows if to some degree if my ten
dollars in my bank account means the
bank owes me ten dollars i have ten
dollars that i can use to go spend now a
sudden i owe the bank i've gone the
other direction and if we use the number
line here it should hopefully make a
little bit of sense so that is zero i'm
starting off with ten dollars i'm
starting off with ten dollars and
spending thirty dollars means i'm moving
thirty spaces to the left
so if i move ten spaces to the left if i
only spend ten dollars i'll be back at
zero if i spend another ten dollars i'll
be at negative 10.
if i spend another 10 dollars after that
i will be at negative i will be at
negative 20. so each of these distances
i spent 10 dollars i'd be at zero
another 10 dollars i'd be at negative
10. another 10 dollars i would be at
negative 20. and this whole distance
right here
is how much i spent i spent
i spent 30 dollars so the general idea
when you spend or if you subtract or if
we're getting colder you would move to
the left of the number line the numbers
would get smaller and we now know they
can get smaller than zero they can go to
negative one negative two they can even
go to negative one point five negative
one point six you're getting more and
more negative the more you lose if
you're adding if i go and get my
paycheck i will move to the right of the
number line
to the right of the number line now with
that out of the way let's just do a
couple of more pure math problems and
just think about what it means if we
were to say
if we were to say
let's say
three
three minus four
so once again this is exactly the
situation that we did here with the
temperature we're starting at three and
we're subtracting four so we're going to
move four to the left we go one two
three four so that gets us to that gets
us to negative one
and when you're starting to do this so
you really understand what a negative
number means i really encourage you to
visualize the number line and really
move along it depending on whether
you're adding and subtracting now let's
do a couple of more let's say i have
let's say i have
2 minus 8
2 minus 8. we'll think about more ways
to do this in future videos but once
again you just want to do the number
line
you have a zero here we're at we're at
let me draw the spacing a little bit
so we have zero here we're at one
two
if we're subtracting eight that means
we're going to move to eight to the left
so we're gonna go one to the left two to
the left so we've gone two to the left
to get to zero we have to move how many
more to the left well we've already
moved two to the left to get to eight we
have to move six more to the left so
we're gonna have to move
one
two
three
four
five six more to the left well where is
that going to put us well we were at
zero this is negative one negative two
negative three
negative four
negative five
negative six
so two minus eight is negative
is negative six you have to move two
minus two would be zero when you're
subtracting eight you're subtracting
another six so we go to negative six we
go six below zero let me do one more
example and this will be a little less
conventional for you but hopefully it
will make sense
let us
let us take and i'll do this in a new
color
let me take
negative 4
minus 2. so we're starting at a negative
number and then we're subtracting from
that and if it just seems confusing just
remember the number line just remember
the number line
so this is 0 right here
this is negative 1 negative 2
negative 3
negative 4. so that's where we're
starting now we're going to subtract 2
from negative 4. so we're going to move
2 to the left so we're gonna go if we
subtract one we will be at negative five
if we subtract another one
we are going to be at negative six
we are going to be at negative six so
this is negative six let's do another
interesting thing let's start
let's start at negative 3.
let's say we have negative 3 instead of
subtracting something from that let's
add let's add 2 to it so where would
this put us on the number line so we're
starting at negative 3
and we're adding 2 so we're going to
move to the right so you add 1 you
become negative 2 but if you add another
1 which we have to do you become
negative 1. you move 2 to the right so
negative 3 plus negative 2 is
it is negative 1. and you could see for
yourself that this all fits our our
traditional notion of adding and
subtracting if we start at negative 1
and we subtract 2 we should get negative
3 it kind of reverses this thing up here
negative 3 plus 2 gets us there then if
we start then we subtract 2 we should
get back to negative 3 and we see that
happens if you start at negative 1
if you start at negative 1 right over
here and you subtract 2 you move 2 to
the left you get back to negative three
so hopefully this starts to give you a
sense of what it means to deal with or
add and subtract negative numbers but
we're going to give a lot more examples
in the next video we're actually going
to see what it means to subtract a
negative number